normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government this
is from the post millennial YouTube
removes Steven Crowder's reporting on
trans Nash Nashville shooter Manifesto
claiming violation of violent criminal
organizations policy so Crowder does
this big breaking story it is now
confirmed verified several pages of the
manifesto I should say of the journal
and documents from the individual
showing an anti-white motivation it may
not be the only motivation but it
appears to be that woke critical race
theory was a component of what drove the
individual to go and take the lives of
several children and faculty members now
right off the bed I just want to say
this I think one of the big reasons why
the the mainstream press and many
political individuals uh politicians are
suppressing that story is not because of
the fear of the privacy or anything like
that violating privacy it's because they
always want to immediately jump to gun
control yeah anytime something like this
happens it's not what was the cause
behind us it was all that matters as
guns yet in Chicago guns don't really
matter in Baltimore it's not really it's
only when there's violent extremism and
I think the issue is whether it be even
whatever you describe identitarian
extremism whether it's Pro or anti-white
they want to use these things for
political gain and they want to uh they
want to uh P push away any
responsibility they may have for their
failed gun policy so I want to say as as
we start this segment shout out go go to
timcast.net
you guys uh did amazing work on this but
let's break this down we've got YouTube
has a bunch of crazy rules on guns they
take it very very seriously now I think
it's fair to a certain degree right
YouTube says no live streaming any kind
of gun content and I'm like their
concern is that someone's going to go on
a rampage but I honestly don't think
that makes sense you can't post any kind
of violent criminal activity on YouTube
at all why ban live streams I think the
big issue YouTube Facebook and uh you
know probably Instagram they don't want
people promoting gun rights in the
United States or anywhere and they can't
just outright remove it but there have
been a bunch of issues that have
happened with uh with YouTube a while
and Google I remember this is a really
funny story back in 2018 YouTube banned
guns from shopping and they were so
stupid they banned Gundam Wing do you
guys know what gundam is oh I know
Gundam Gundam is an anime and it's g n d
m and they're giant fighting Japanese
robots in space and you and Google
banned people trying to buy it cuz they
were trying to suppress the word gun so
I certainly think it's overtly political
and they want to they they are working
let me just add this to it when we
learned uh a while ago but now with
confirmation from from the GOP that the
government is colluding with Stanford
University and big Tech organizations to
silence and suppress the rights of
individuals absolutely YouTube and
Facebook are taking a political stance
to suppress our rights first and second
I don't get is I feel like I see these
videos on YouTube of like a dude walking
into a shop and then the guy the shop
pulls out his weapon and Fires at the
guy and like they're all on YouTube what
what do you mean like movie what's that
like a movie no no like like security
camera footage of of a a guy coming
intoa store are you sure cuz I'll
see but like it'll be like a guy doing
doc talking about the video and then the
guy will walk in and he'll pull out the
gun and like if it's like a mainstream
media channel I remember after some of
the mass shootings that happened there
were and the whole monetization video um
issue came about on YouTube uh like
Jimmy Fallon Tonight Jimmy Kimmel all of
these people were able to do videos
about the mass shootings that were
monetized but no one else could so you
may have seen that on mainstream media
channels that have goad there are a
couple couple channels that do cover
that there's one called active self-
protection which uh I forget the guy's
name but he actually covers
International stuff A lot of times
you'll have stuff from South America but
he it's always some kind of security
footage and you will go over what could
have been done better if it was an
actual self-defense shooting if it was
just not monetized though um operat
don't imag does
that million subscribers Donuts so I
think we yeah he I I don't want to talk
about the strategies people use to get
her won isues yeah it's not
straightforward let's put that no it's
not yeah and we know there are a lot of
very serious rules I remember that a
bunch of the big gun YouTubers were
talking about the restrictions that were
placed and they're weird and hard to
understand but I think it's fair to say
YouTube taking down this Manifesto
serves nothing but the gun control
narrative and the left liberal
establishment narrative if if it if it
comes out it's it's not just about guns
don't get me wrong it's also about
critical race Theory diversity Equity
inclusion it's like uh oh the extremist
ideology of the left is resulting in
extremist taking action as a component
there's more to this story we haven't
gotten the full release here but I think
a core component is there are powerful
interests that want to ban guns in
government and the private sector and it
is beneficial if you can shut down any
motivating uh any any information on
motivation so then when no one knows
what happened you can say guess we got
to ban guns y I'm concerned that like
and I always hate to pin it on the CCP
because I want the United States and
China to be allies long term but like
for them to be like hey alphabet
Google's parent company money money
money you want to you want to roll in
China we don't want you to have certain
uh gun rights things and like what are
they really trying to get the United
States to screw Itself by removing its
own amendments like come on like our our
constitutions more important an
incorporate oligarchy and we cannot let
foreigners stop us from exercising our
rights and and cherishing our
rights yeah it's actually I mean there's
always the point of oh why arm yourself
the government's so powerful they'll
just nuke you whatever well it's
actually very hard to fight large you
know populations that are all armed and
spread out in a diaspora you know
whether you're in rice fields or in the
Middle East it's always proven difficult
and if you can just psychologically
disarm a population by convincing them
that they don't want or need or even
have these things in their awareness so
funny actually when I was checking in
for my flight on the way here there was
a sign behind us that said uh declare if
you have a gun and the Canadian guy
standing beside me was asking the lady
do a lot of people actually bring guns
from here Vancouver and the lady was
like oh believe it or not they do and
he's like I thought no one owned them
and this was a conversation I witnessed
they want that to be the average
person's thought process they want the
average person to not even conceptualize
or conceive that why would I need a gun
no one does that term it's a longterm
strategy right yeah so they they've been
largely successful I think honestly like
unless you're a person that is it it
tends to be people that are pro second
amendment in the US they tend to be
people that are also politically
motivated politically active there the
reason that there hasn't been success in
the US with significant uh anti-gun
legislation and gun control the reason
that there's been victories for the past
20 or so years so predominantly is
because of the fact that the people that
are prun are so politically active the
idea that there's a lot of money going
to individual Congress people from the
gun industry that's a fallacy the money
that's going to the to the the money
that that is actually big money is from
rathon they're making missile batteries
they're making drones they're making
serious uh you know the kind of Weaponry
that's sold to States the the companies
that make small arms generally don't
have these big contracts and they're not
giving tons of money the idea that the
NRA is responsible is a fallacy most gun
uh gun owners really look at the NRA as
a meme and as a joke and it's it's the
it's where all the fuds go you know so
the idea that that the the that it's
something other than Grassroots
preventing significant legislation
that's all a fallacy but I I think we're
winning yeah for sure we're so lucky
that the century was televised and
recorded because what Hitler did was so
egregious he disarmed his population
then sent in the shock troops to control
them and that will never happen again
well I think you got a correction for us
sorry I think you got a correction for
what he just said Yeah well yeah me it's
in the documentary yeah that's right you
know there's a meme that says there's a
meme that says that Hitler um you know
he he he took all the guns right but it
actually started right after World War
one and uh and and Germany you know you
know because they lost the war they they
had to uh they they had to abide by the
Treaty of Versa and in that treaty was
required that they disarm the citizens
so it was Japan that was 1920 right 1919
1920 so it was the Allies that actually
required that of Germany to disarm the
population so they disarmed the enemy
they so they used a policy that was
already in place against the people and
this is what's so interesting is we
always say like oh we're going to put in
these policies for our side of politics
like for the lefties but you guys don't
realize that as soon as a government
that you really disagree with gets in
power they can utilize those polit
policies against
you Germany an important point that was
brought up in infringed in 1920
Germany's forced to disarm their
population in 1928 they reintroduce
permitting and gun registry you want own
a gun you got to prove why you that you
need it for a legitimate reason to
defend yourself and then you can apply
for a permit and register and then
you're on the list now you're on the
list and when the Nazis come to power
they have have a list of everyone who is
armed and they start hunting those
people down and then of course the Nazis
too they relaxed gun restrictions for
Nazi Party members but then if you're a
Jew you you are not allowed to own a gun
so again gun control is not about your
safety gun control is not about
controlling guns it's about using guns
to control you and this is like why
these lists are so important too like
the Registries in Canada the long gun
Registries they tried to put in right
now actually um this Jan anuary the ATF
are bringing in you need to register
your stabilizing braces with the ATF or
you need to hand in modified guns with
them these Registries are all to be
used Phil didn't the the Supreme Court
overturn the the pistol brace currently
there is a stay on the enforcement of
the pistol brace it's only for people
that are members of Goa and FPC which
are both great uh great proun uh
organizations Firearms policy coalition
and Gun Owners of America but you but
they they have the the actual lawsuit
against the ATF and so their members are
are covered under the state only their
members only their members what if you
sign up right now you can join now and
you will be a you will be covered by the
the state but you have to be a member of
either the Firearms policy Coalition
it's gun policy uh it's at gun policy on
Twix and uh or you have to be a member
of Goa uh both are great I'm a little
partial to Firearms policy coalition cuz
they're a little more Hoist the Black
Flag kind of dudes and I like that um
but you have to be cover you have to be
a member of either of those two
otherwise a brace is currently a felony
and you'll get 10 years
$250,000 fine if you have a braced uh an
AR-15 they'll basically just they'll be
treating it as a short barrel rifle
unless you're a member of those I think
I'm a member of like all of them to be
honest I think like one day I just went
to like every gun rights organization
started donating what does it take to
become part of it a donation send give
your
information so like for for Canada to
have a gun license you have to have a
gun club that you're a part of or a
range that you're a member of right you
have to have your pal your R pal if you
want to own anything that's got some
real Firepower kick behind it and um you
got to have like your ammo guns separate
guns have to be locked a trigger lock on
them ammunition you know what do you
guys have any of that comparable yes
depends where we have we have a handful
of states that uh for 2 as the Evil 7
the evil he's right yeah and um you know
when I lived in New Jersey we had some
some security you know uh uh concerns
and this is before I bought a gun so I
decid you know I I need to get a gun why
well the cops told me well I I was told
by a cop if it were me I'd answer the
door with a shotgun that's all he didn't
say go buy a gun he was like you know
what I'm saying and I'm like okay and
then I was told by the police if someone
were to try to break into my home I I
can do nothing if someone is actively at
my door smashing out the window and
reaching and open the door I cannot take
action against that person it's like
Canada cuz it would be murder now if he
breaks into your home now it's a
different story because if he breaks
into your home you are legally required
to flee your home and you still can't
defend yourself like Canada and and uh
and I said where would I go I'm in my
house this is where I live and then what
what I was told was when you tell that
to a judge you are saying in court I
would rather kill a man than stand
outside and that's the way the court
will will interpret what you are saying
and that is considered unreasonable and
they said only if you are trapped and I
said so if I'm backed into a corner with
no doors and a guy in front of me I can
shoot him then and and what if he dies
say okay that's the best part you will
now have an affirmative defense after we
arrest you and charge you with a felony
and you spend six months in prison you
can tell a judge you were trapped
hopefully he believes you and I was like
holy crap Maryland's a little better if
you are outside your house Watering your
lawn and a guy comes up to you
threatening you you must run into your
house if the man then tries to break
into your house this this is the what I
am told by law enforcement you can then
defend yourself so actually to a much
greater degree than New Jersey uh but
West Virginia by far is is is is
substantially better West Virginia you
can be on any property whether you're
indoors or outdoors and if you are
threatened you can defend yourself you
can't just shoot anybody this is not
true like someone walks in your property
you're like aha you know he's coming
right for me but if you are threatened
and you can justify the threat Florida
is even crazier and Texas too stand your
ground you know very little problem
because you could be anywhere legally
you know West Virginia also it it is
still very similar if you're in West
Virginia you're constitutional career
you're walking around someone threatens
you and you have reasonable fear of of
great bodily harm or death you can
defend yourself dude I was in Florida uh
last like three weeks ago for for like 3
weeks and I was I was feeling that the
the the concealed carry thing I was
walking around like at night and looking
at people I'm like they all probably
have guns just to everyone's got a gun
and they're all looking at me and
thinking he's probably got a gun and we
all just have massive respect other it's
called her immunity yeah I mean that if
you are in a place where you can legally
carry a gun I mean essentially you are
kind of rolling the dice like that
person may have a gun do I really want
is is the fact that he bumped into me or
looked at me wrong is it worth making
comment over because maybe it escalates
to something very bad and if you're
carrying a gun you definitely need you
have to know that you can't just be like
oh that guy's giv me a dirty look so I'm
just gonna Mean Mug him all night long
because you're responsible for
de-escalating these are things that you
have to you know exactly what one thing
that always bothered me growing up in
Chicago is that I had friends who would
road rage and I'd be like people who
weren't from the southide who didn't get
it I guess and they'd either come from
different neighborhoods or from the
suburbs we'd be driving on the highway
someone would cut them off and they they
they switch the lanes getting get you
know speed up and start flicking them
off and screaming at them and I'm like
bro do you know how many stories I can
tell you about a dude getting shot in
the face because he decided to road rage
out for no reason I'm not saying that
you know you you've got to you got to
back down I'm saying choose your battles
you ain't gaining Nothing by screaming
at a dude in the highway and swerving
around if someone cuts you off choose
your battles just it happens man don't
get out don't get B out of shape but
dude some people I knew would rage out
and there's so many stories where
there's dudes with illegal guns now I
don't think they I actually don't think
the guns should be illegal to be
completely honest people who have
acquired guns in ways the state does not
like but you have a right to keep in be
arms that being said they they they
acquire these guns in illegal ways and
that means they do not have good
intentions and you can't defend yourself
from them because you can't have a gun
now because of uh DC versus heler you
can have guns but they still make it
near impossible and only recently I
think there's still issues with Maryland
Maryland was um was an impra practice no
issue State meaning even even though
they say you can apply for a permit they
would never give you one New York was
similar New Jersey was similar now with
the latest was it Bruin I think the
latest supreme court hearing they're
like you have to give permits if people
request one so uh now I think Maryland's
still giving people the business but New
York has started issuing permits so I
the the Catalyst for me leaving
Massachusetts and going to New Hampshire
was the the the last draw was when I
went to the police officer and the went
through the whole rigor MO asked for a
license to carry and the issuing officer
just flat out said we don't give them
out in the town that I'm in and I'm like
what do you mean you don't give them out
and this is back in 2010 or so thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net